your Herald summons you another world
awaits let it be done quickly
[Music]
what happy here happy Hogan here I know
what do you want over it mr. Starks
going through his belongings apparently
it was a surfboard that you left behind
people over there said they think that
Nick here was a surfer guys sake
appearance is gonna be juicy not mine
don't ever call this number again
welcome back everyone is Charlie we have
news about the Marvel Silver Surfer
movie that they're working on obviously
we have that Easter Egg during
spider-man far from home so we'll break
it all down we're doing the giveaway for
spider-man far from home on blu-ray all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave your best Silver
Surfer theory on the video the reason
why they included that in spider-man far
from home is the same reason why they
included that Fantastic Four Easter Egg
at the end on the billboards side and
then the one in Nick Fury's sword Space
Station in the post-credits scene
because when they were making spider-man
far from home the Disney Fox Steel had
not cleared yet so they could have been
sued out of existence so that's why you
don't see Fantastic Four characters
walking around in spider-man far from
home or the Silver Surfer show up at the
end of Avengers endgame they just didn't
get the rights to the character fast
enough to do the CG that would have been
required for something like that
recently we all saw Kevin Feige
announced the Fantastic Four movie
reboot plants during the Marvel phase
for Comic Con panel right now the rumor
is is that movie could happen as soon as
2022 in there's news of a Silver Surfer
movie after that we've been hearing
rumors about a Silver Surfer movie all
year long people even thought that he
might show up at the end of Avengers end
game for a little while I've already
done a couple videos on the Fantastic
Four teasers that we've gotten so far so
this video is just gonna be about the
Silver Surfer movie earlier this year
director Adam McKay said that he
intended to meet with Kevin Feige to
talk about doing an actual Silver Surfer
movie at the same event Kevin Feige also
talked about Silver Surfer and future
stuff that was coming we're I not on
this carpet talking you right now I'd be
in the cutting room and on the mixed age
where the rest of the team is right the
second
you spoke recently about obviously the
coming merger and it's a little
premature to get too deep into things I
don't know if you heard I spoke to McKay
the other day Adam McKay said Silver
Surfer movie I might you know I might
need to give Feige a call have you
gotten the call I've not gotten a call
yet but I've seen Adam tonight and at a
number of these awards and he is not
only as everybody knows incredibly smart
guy he's a honest-to-goodness fan yeah
and and you know he did a lot of sort of
behind the scenes help with us on the
first ant-man film and have you seen
Vice cameo little actus cameo in there
we helped him get so I look forward to
speaking with him or if there is there a
Fox property you're you're just excited
to potentially get your hands on a
particular that the truth is I'm excited
for all of them I'm excited and it's not
just the marquee names you know there
are hundreds of names on those on those
documents on those agreements and the
fact that Marvel is as close as we may
ever get now to having access to all of
the characters is something I've been
dreaming about for my almost 20 years at
Marvel and it's very exciting
Mikey he said he just sung your praises
a moment ago he sounds like he really
wants to make this work I assume there's
been no movement you haven't called him
since our talk about Silver Surfer some
discussion about Silver Surfer my agents
certainly woke up they were excited
we're in the middle of you know backing
vice right now but who knows in a couple
months it could pop up I really am
excited by that idea most of you are
probably familiar with Adam McKay from
all of his work with Will Ferrell and
all the movies and Saturday Night Live
stuff that they did together but for the
past several years Marvel has been using
him as a script doctor on their movies
going all the way back to the first
ant-man movie they bring him in to punch
up scripts when they're shooting movies
he's an amazing writer and he's actually
a pretty good director in his own right
too and he's a lifelong Silver Surfer
Stan a Silver Surfer movie would be the
perfect opportunity for him to do his
first big MCU movie himself instead of
just being a lowly uncredited script
doctor side note he's also behind the
succession TV show that's on HBO right
now starring Brian
who was himself a big x-men character
for a long time but right now aside from
the Silver Surfer Fantastic Four Easter
eggs in the Marvel phase three movies
Marvel has not backed itself into a
corner with an Odin's vault Infinity
Gauntlet situation that they'll be
forced to pay off so they can bring an
actual Silver Surfer any way that they
want with any kind of story typically
that's been through Fantastic Four
stories because silver surfers first
appearance in the comics was during a
Fantastic Four storyline called wait for
it the Galactus trilogy Stan Lee tells
this great story about how they wanted
to do Galactus so they had the idea for
that character first inside the
Fantastic Four comics the way Stan Lee
tells it Jack Kirby showed up one day
with a bunch of artwork in this weird
dude walking around with a silver
surfboard so Jack Kirby explained the
concept to him saying that
well if Galactus is this huge character
literally huge then he would probably
have minions going around the universe
helping him so that's where the Silver
Surfer came from he was on the Fantastic
Four team for a little while but then
they turned the character into this
observer of humanity and used him to
comment on the human condition this is a
clip of Stan Lee talking about the
philosophy of the Silver Surfer
character and it gives you a good
template for how the character is going
to be used when he's working with all
the Avengers characters in Marvel phase
5 and Beyond he would drain all the
energy out of a planet to keep himself
alive he was huge and he had this huge
spaceship and he didn't want to harm
anybody but he had to live and instead
of just a guy flying around fighting for
finding planets I made him a
philosophical observer of the world and
the universe and I had him talking semi
Shakespearean and biblical language and
he became my mouthpiece for how I feel
about a lot of things I told Jack I want
to use this character a lot and he came
to earth and he would say things like
and I don't remember the exact words
I'll just paraphrase it but he would
talk about the fact that we live in the
greatest planet we could ever want it
has everything it has
clean fresh air in a sunlight moonlight
it has all the water we could need most
of the planet is water it has beautiful
growing things all the food we could one
room for everybody why do we fight each
other why do we hate each other why is
there chrome what's the matter with us
are we insane
it's always fun to listen to Stanley
talk about the origins to some of these
characters because when Kevin Feige
talks about them he talks about them in
the exact same way when they introduce
really big comic book characters like
this they try to be as true to the
origins of the character as possible
what they were originally intended to be
used for but just on a practical level a
Silver Surfer spin-off movie would
obviously spin probably out of a
Fantastic Four movie in which is deal
with his origins Norrin Radd where he
came from how he came to be Galactus is
Herald when she show all that history
you show him then in present day working
with the other current Avengers roster
whatever that new roster is going to be
I haven't done a whole lot of Avengers 5
videos yet because a lot of the new
Avengers team members will be the new
characters that show up during Marvel
phase 4 probably the biggest surprise is
kit harington's Black Knight being on a
future Avengers team that's something
that I would never guessed Kit Harington
1 being in an Avengers movie into even
bigger surprise the Black Knight being
in an Avengers movie if you've never
seen it really the only other big
cinematic appearance of the Silver
Surfer was in Fantastic Four 2 when
Chris Evans was still playing the
character it's not a good movie but
Laurence Fishburne does the voice for
the character Laurence Fishburne now in
the MCU is playing Goliath so hopefully
when they bring Silver Surfer in they'll
have some sort of Laurence Fishburne
Easter egg in the background if they're
able to include that character sometimes
that doesn't always happen he wasn't
anywhere to be found during avengers
endgame that was a bit of a surprise too
but they also didn't include a whole lot
of Hank Pym Janet Van Dyne until the
very very end if they really are able to
get their Fantastic Four movie out by
2022 I would say Silver Surfer movie
would probably be the year or two after
that let me know in the comments though
who is your fan cast for the new Silver
Surfer in the MCU
could be anybody from their late 20s to
early 40s I imagine it probably would be
a whole lot older than that but if they
find a fantastic actor like if Keanu
Reeves actually wants to be the Silver
Surfer Kevin Feige would probably
Bend time in space to make that happen
that's how the blade movie wound up
getting green lit because Marvel had no
intentions of doing a blade movie before
Hershel alley walked in the door since
it's still really early days I'm not
expecting to get a whole lot of news
about Fantastic Four or Silver Surfer
movies till at least next year sometime
next year's Comic Con panel is when
you'll really start hearing about that
stuff but Kevin Feige did say that they
would start teasing all the really big
stuff x-men fantastic for the next big
threat after Thanos which is probably
gonna wind up being khalaqtu s' during
all the Marvel phase 4 projects so
that's why it's important to watch the
TV shows as well as the movies when they
drop there will be a Black Widow trailer
coming late November early December
that's just when Marvel usually drops
its spring trailer they did the same
thing for Avengers infinity war in
Avengers endgame in the last two years
so when we get new footage or if we hear
any big news I will totally do a video
for it but leave all your requests in
the comments below
congratulations Ryan Hilton you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my new
spider-man far from home post credits
scene venom teaser Marvel phase 4 teaser
breakdown in Easter eggs and click here
for my video about Quicksilver coming
back during Doctor Strange - thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]